all right now we can keep on going there
are other interesting results that we
can see if it is for example the
hyperbola now we have seen a hyperbola
before it notice that it gives us some
read things like when we looked at the
equalities it was strange
right what is up what is this going to
tell us about the hyperbola well for
starters I suppose since we're
differentiating powers of X right we
ought to phrase this as a power of X
what is one of X good it's the
derivative of the derivative of that is
the derivative of this okay please don't
leave off your derivative there and just
say it's equal to that because it's the
derivative of this that's the dream of
this because that makes it okay so here
is the first thing when you
differentiate constant now we
differentiate a hyperbola okay let's see
what happens look at the rule look at
how we used it before this power is
gonna come out in the front right slappa
by this sign here and then the power of
here should reduce by one right and
minus one now it's currently negative
one so if I take away one from that
it'll become negative two do you agree
with that now this is a bit weird let's
let's go back to our I'll get rid of a
big amid this isn't that cozy this is
minus one over x squared okay now you
want to be suspicious of this a little
bit because just think about how we've
developed this rule think about how we
developed it what did we do yes
how's it going down yeah okay all right
so so to pull you back to where our
heads had to go to develop this right I
relied on a particular result I relied
on this result what did I have
I had this right because I had to do
sorry for that's not what happened
oh yeah kind of I had to do this do you
remember this
do you remember why I had to do this
right I was putting this guy right
through the first principles thing right
so this is f of X plus h you ruined that
right and then I had a factorization for
this yeah and then I had all these terms
oh no no no no and then I expanded out
and I did some cool algebraic tricks
okay but if I pull this same thing over
here for this
what happens to my it would be either
businessing you get the same result just
without a missile what is this this is
this isn't it yeah so it's like am i
getting the same expansion something
different seems to be happening like I
don't have this kind of thing right so
you should pose the question like can I
just take advantage of this pattern I
noticed before which just had to do with
positive numbers right and doesn't
necessarily keep working when you throw
in a span up like that okay now we have
two tools at our disposal you have to
choose and we're gonna use both okay the
first tool is just look back on the
board right what is this thing supposed
to be it's it's meant to be the gradient
isn't it like we write out the
derivative but the point of the
derivative is that it gives you the
gradient okay so we know what one on X
what it looks like so we ought to be
able to think about what its great it
looks like right so draw me a couple of
sets access to small ones we only need
to draw 1 over X and draw them one
underneath the other because we're gonna
make some comparisons
there's whatever apps weren't very very
familiar with one over X minus whatever
x squared
not so familiar but that doesn't make it
hard to graph what kind of things is
this thing doing number one it's even
symmetry because there's an even power
right so I really need to graph one half
of this and then I'll get the other half
by reflecting secondly there are some
asymptotes on this thing right I can
think of two what's the easiest one that
you can see x equals so just say zero
say I've got a vertical asymptote of x
equals zero right because I've got zero
XL denominator so I've got a vertical
asymptote
right on the y-axis okay and then I have
another asymptote is it or horizontal or
oblique it's gonna be horizontal because
the degree of the bottom is rather
larger than the degree of the top right
zero versus two okay so therefore I've
got a horizontal asymptote at and you
can fairly easily see it's going to be y
equals zero okay so you've noticed
you've noticed it's it's even symmetry
I've got a couple of asymptotes right
what else can you tell me about this
graph if you want to do regions for
example what would the region's tell you
it's always going to be negative right
it must always be negative you can
figure out of two ways number one you
can think okay this is a factor negative
1 this is also a factor it's always
positive and negative and a positive are
always going to multiply or divide
together to give you a navy right or of
course you can just think wow this thing
is always gonna be positive so what you
divided and they can know by that you
always remain so I'm gonna be down here
yep what else can you tell me do you
need to tell me anything else yeah
yeah yeah kinda okay so if you imagine a
parabola here right a parabola in here
okay oh yeah sorry it's upside down so
if I divide by a really really big
negative number down here okay a really
huge negative number then I'm gonna be
minus one over a really huge seven Megan
oh so be very small
right which is why as you told me before
I have this I should label y equals zero
horizontal asymptote right and then as I
approach over here that upside-down
parabola is becoming closer and closer
to zero right so therefore when you
divide by something closer and closer to
zero you race off to negative infinity
there's one that hopefully guy he's the
other because you told him right over
beginning even symmetry okay yeah
correct because it's x squared that's
right so what that really means is it's
actually going to be steeper but the
general shape is all we needed now let's
have a look there's my own here's my
gradient function is this an accurate
reflection of our original hyperbola
let's have a think about it so it's
gradient for example over here okay I'm
gonna put the slides on like I did
before
okay is this gradient over on this side
is it negative or positive it's negative
isn't it cuz it's decreasing decreasing
decreasing decreasing decreasing okay so
this is right this is negative down here
what about off through pass x equals
zero it's still decreasing isn't it
negative negative negative negative so
so far so good
okay but it's more than just negative
isn't it right it's not like a straight
line for instance what is this telling
us about the gradient over here it's up
for example over here
over here it's negative but it's quite
close to zero isn't it
right when a gradient is close to zero
what does that tell you about the lion
it's almost straight it's it's kind of
like this situation I suppose where I
could say is cuz it's not actually
Australia it's shallow which sure enough
it's shallow here it's decreasing but
not very much now as you moved closer
and closer to x equals zero what's
happening
your gradients dropping off like a rock
what does that mean it's getting super
steep over here right as you get closer
of course as it should cuts an asymptote
right okay and then what's happening
over here will exactly the verse right
it starts off really really really
negative the gradient okay which means
what it's super steep and then it
shallows out just like you'd expect okay
so visually it looks like it checks out
right looks like it checks out the only
problem with doing things visually is
that uh your eyes can be very deceiving
for example if I hold out if I hold out
this some land yard right and I do I do
something like this okay
now I know this there's two lines there
but just imagine doing one now this [ __ ]
looks kind of like a parabola doesn't it
it looks parabolic so what off doesn't
it except it's not it's not a parabola
at all it looks like one but it's not
it's a completely different shape it's
called a um I don't even know how this
is properly pronounced container eight I
think right you go look it up right all
all hanging chains or strings do this
when they hang over there in wet looks
like a parabola but it's not this so far
looks like it checks out but how can you
really know like this is a pretty blood
tool right yeah
yep yep I couldn't still exist cuz it
would the gradients will be right hold
on you lost me
I mean put this up here know what is
yeah cuz it's decreasing secrecy so it's
kinda stayed out there
it must absolutely be negative okay I
figured out this is everywhere that this
graph is defined which is everywhere
except for x equals zero it's always
every point is going down every point is
going down they're going down at
different rates
but it has to be it's got to be negative
it's got to be on there the gradient
function has to be negative
yeah okay you could test points for
scale that would work you'd say like
here and yeah and you could actually
draw in some like you know some some
secant and see what's going on okay
that'll work you tell the problem with
that is that there's still sequence
aren't they okay and so they're still
going to be approximate right we have a
better tool for this we have a precise
tool we're going to go back to first
principles